welcome to exploring computing
today's video is website design
so in this video we're going to talk a
bit about website design
and i want to focus mostly on branding
and the idea behind branding is
you want to make your website unique and
clearly identifiable
and the idea here is if your website
looks like everybody else's website
people aren't going to notice it and
let's say somebody emails
a link to your website to one of their
friends
that friend visits that page says oh
this is pretty cool
and then the next day somebody else
sends
a link to another page on your website
to that same person
and what you want to have happen is when
they click on that link you want them to
say wait a minute i think i've been to
this website before
i recognize this website this is a
different page
but yeah this is the same website i went
to yesterday this this
website seems to have some really cool
stuff i should be paying attention to
this website
and so in this video we're going to talk
about some things that are
going to help you make your website
unique identifiable
and interesting okay so here are the
four elements of branding we're going to
be talking about today we're going to be
talking about
logo briefly uh
typography in particular font choices
and color schemes and then i'll talk a
little bit about uh overall layout and
what you should be thinking in terms of
navigation
all right so the main thing i want to
say about your logo is
you need to make sure that your logo is
clearly identifiable and appears
on all your web pages or at least some
version you can have a simplified
version on the inner pages and then like
a fancy version on
on the main home page the thing to keep
in mind here is that
if you have a successful website people
are going to be doing what's called
deep linking and so that means is that
people are going to be linking to
individual pages deep within your
website
i think one thing that many amateurs
often think
is that oh i'm just going to focus on
the branding on the home page because
everybody's going to be coming through
the home page
and that is just not true you know if
you think about
web page links that you've sent to
friends you know there's probably been
many times when you've been like oh
here's a particular product
uh that's part of a larger website i
want to go ahead and send somebody like
this or here's a movie review
you know and this is an inner page on a
larger website
and so this is deep linking and so
always keep in mind
and we'll talk about this again we're
talking about navigation schemes that
people
are not necessarily coming through the
front door so
you know you need to have your website
clearly identifiable from
any one of the web pages
all right so one of the key design
choices you're going to be making
for your website is what to use for
fonts
and we're going to be talking about
three fundamental font choices
and they are you can use a sans-serif
font a serif font or a mono space font
and as we'll see when we take a look at
real web pages
real web pages often use a mix of these
but you know most of them
are primarily either sansef or serif
monospace is used for special purposes
that we'll be talking about a little bit
later
all right so let's make sure everybody
understands what these serifs are and
what sans serif is so on the left i have
a sans serif font and on the right i
have a serif font
and those little tick marks uh
on the ends of uh the f here
those are the serifs
so here's what the design people will
tell you about serif versus sans serif
fonts
serif fonts are formal and authoritative
although the flip side of that view is
serif fonts are
old-fashioned and dowdy and
sans-serif fonts are upbeat and
contemporary so you need to think about
what the purpose of your website is
and whether you'd rather be contemporary
or authoritative when choosing your font
so let's take a look at some actual
websites and see which one of these font
choices they're making
so what do you think do you think the
new york times wants to be
upbeat and contemporary or do you think
they want to be authoritative
okay so here's the new york times um we
look at
up at the top their actual title there
that seems pretty seraphi
and if you look at the news stories here
you can see that they have serifs as
well and there is some sans serif
over on the right side that whole
sidebar
is largely sans serif and up at the top
right underneath the name the new york
times if you look at the world u.s
politics new york business that's all
sans serif as well
and so we scroll a little bit further
down the website you'll notice that this
webpage is largely serifs
and the news articles themselves are
serifs and so that kind of makes sense
if you think about like what's new york
times probably trying to portray here
they're trying to portray that they are
formal and authoritative
what about the washington post
so the washington post also largely uh
has a lot of serifs here um although
again as with the new york times if you
look at underneath
the uh the title there that bar going
across
the top in the news coronavirus news dc
outbreak and so on that sans serif
um you can see some other places where
they're using sans serif
the writers of the articles those names
are
sans serif and if you look at the actual
text
uh of the articles here if you look at
that center america's chronovirus divide
and you look at
the text there the question of whether
or not the country should continue to
stay at home
that's actually sans serif
all right what about msnbc
so they're trying to be more
contemporary uh i offhand do not see
any serifs on this webpage at all
so that kind of got me thinking like
i think msnbc's uh rather left-wing
and so is there a difference between how
left-wing institutions and right-wing
institutions portray themselves and so
i thought we'd take a look at a couple
think tanks here now the brookings
institute
that's the center left think tank and
you can see that
their name brookings there on the top
left that has saris but
in fact their website largely other than
their name
uh you know which may have been
uh that that font may have been chosen
quite a while ago
now the rest of the website has no
serifs at all
and then the heritage foundation which
is a conservative think tank
you can see that this is largely a serif
website
there are some sans-serif portions so
running across the top there about
heritage event renewed donate press and
contact
those are sans serif but their logo
itself
the heritage foundation the top left and
their main article here
these all have serifs
okay so based on what we know about uh
font choices
which type of font you think apple
computer is going to use
and here we go there are no serifs here
on at the top of the apple page and if
we scroll down even further you can see
yeah
the apple has no series at all there
they want the contemporary upbeat look
they are not interested in being
old-school
authoritative formal no not apple
okay here's one more the mandarin
oriental new york this is a five-star
hotel
in new york what font choice do you
think they would have
all right and so here you go uh this is
largely
serifs and there is some sans serif so
if you look across the top there
um their top bar does have
sans-serif font and in fact if you were
to click on the menu
that also has sans serif but the new
york
as well as the rest of the website
there all has serifs
okay i mentioned monospace so let's talk
a little bit about monospace
so your primary choices are serif or
sans-serif
there is another type of font monospace
and actually model space fonts can have
serifs or they can be sans serifs
in a mono space font all the characters
are the same width
so here i've got a non-monospace font
and notice
m i w i m notice that the
eyes are much much narrower than the m's
which
you know that's kind of what you'd
expect so uh this font where
the ms and the i's are different sizes
this is referred to as a variable width
or proportional font
[Music]
in contrast here's a monospace font i've
got
m-i-w-i-m on the bottom there
and if you look it's a little hard to
tell for sure but you can kind of see
that the eyes there are much
wider so than with our
non-monospace font so um
m i w i m
it looks like on the bottom font those
eyes are much wider than with the
non-monospaced font and in fact
we can definitely see this if we reverse
the letters here
so here's our variable with font
m-i-w-i-m
followed by i-m-i-w-i
both these quote words
have five letters each in them and you
can see that the second one
because it has a lot of eyes which are
super narrow is much shorter than the
top one
now we switched to a monospace font uh
you can see that these actually are both
the same width so that's the basic idea
behind a monospace one
all the characters are the same width
amount of space fonts are typically used
to
either represent program code or
computer output so
if we've got a our html source i
actually have not been using monospace
for
all of our code mostly because monospace
fonts take up a lot of space
but it's pretty common to use monospace
for computer code and in fact if you
look at
an editor for example so here is here's
visual studio code and the default
setting
uh on any one of these editors designed
for programmer use is going to use some
sort of a mono space font
it just makes it easier to get
everything all lined up
okay so our next topic is choosing a
color scheme
and in order to understand how to choose
a color scheme
we actually need to learn a little bit
more about color theory so we've been
using red green and blue rgb and rgb
is how the computer monitor actually
creates colors but
there are other ways to be thinking
about colors and one of them is
the huge saturation brightness or hsb
scheme and that's the one we're going to
be using
okay so the first part of hsb is the hue
and so the hue you can kind of think of
hues as the colors of the rainbow that
are the colors of the color spectrum and
so that's what we're looking at here
now in addition to choosing a hue i can
also vary the saturation
so what we're seeing here is that on the
left i have full saturation and i'm
reducing the saturation on the far right
i have very little saturation
and if i reduce the saturation enough
i'm just going to end up with white in
addition to controlling the saturation
i can also control the brightness and so
that's what we're seeing here on the far
left i have maximum brightness and
i'm getting less and less light and then
on the far right i have no brightness
which is basically black
okay so as i suggested rgb that's how
the computer display actually creates
colors and hsb
uh is a scheme that people often use to
choose
determine what their color scheme should
be and so
you may be wondering what is the
relationship between the rgb
and the hsb that we're showing you now
and
honestly it's there's just a simple
mathematical formula to go from one to
the other so you know
we're not talking about creating
different colors we're just talking
about a different way to be thinking
about colors
so based on what we know so far one
possible color scheme
is to just choose a hue and then just to
vary the color by
reducing the saturation or increasing or
reducing the brightness so this would be
called a monochromatic color scheme and
this certainly works
and it's not going to look horrible but
it may not look that exciting either so
you know this may be not be the way you
want to go
for our other color schemes uh we want
to
understand a bit about how to choose the
hue and
typically we're going to choose the hue
by using what's called a color wheel
so let's go about creating a color wheel
i'm going to start off with our three
primary colors and remember
on the computer we're using additive
color so our three primary colors on the
computer are red green and blue
and what then what i'm going to do is
i'm going to mix the colors i'm going to
mix
each color with the color next to it so
i'm going to mix
red with blue getting some form of
purple
i'm going to mix the green
with the red and that will get me yellow
and i will mix
the green with the blue and that will
actually give me cyan
and by mixing each of the three colors
with its nearest neighbor
that gives us the six color color wheel
and that's what we're looking at here
and then i can do it again which will
get me the 12 color color wheel and then
i can keep on going as many times as i
want and in fact
if you were to take a look at adobe
photoshop
and and many other painting programs
they have color wheels built in so
uh the outer ring here what we're seeing
is
uh we're seeing the color wheel
generated by
over and over and over again mixing the
colors with its nearest neighbor until
we get a continuous range of colors here
and then that triangle in the middle
that is actually
the saturation and brightness so
the bottom left is no brightness
and then the top left is no saturation
and so you can kind of play around with
how much saturation versus brightness
you want to get
okay so how are we going to use this
color wheel to create color schemes
well there's a number of different color
schemes one can create
using the color wheel one color scheme
choice the simplest color scheme choices
complementary colors in complementary
colors
we take a color on one side of the color
wheel and then we choose a color
on the immediate opposite side of the
color wheel and so
here we've got blue and yellow and
if you have any friends or you've got a
brother or sister who's
in one of the university of california
schools
most of the university of california
schools have some variation of this
blue and and yellow color scheme so
cal has dark blue and gold
the colors we're showing here are pretty
close to uc irvine colors
now ucla i think has more of a powder
blue and
uh yellow or gold um so these seem to
work
pretty well on the other hand if you
kind of look at
what this thing should match up with our
cardinal red
well as far as i can tell this suggests
that we should have some variation of
cyan
uh which i personally think that will
look just awful so
oh well but anyway this is how you
create a complementary color scheme
so another thing you could do if you
want more than two colors you can use a
split complementary scheme and so
what happens here is i take a color on
one side of the color wheel and i choose
two colors on the opposite side of the
color wheel and you can kind of play
around with the angle
between the two colors on the opposite
side of the color wheel to get some
different color schemes
or you can have a triad color scheme
where all three of the colors are equal
distance across the color wheel
or you can have an analogous color
scheme where you're choosing colors that
are near each other on the color wheel
i mean you can kind of play around again
with that angle there
i've only got 12 colors so there's not a
whole lot you can do with the angle but
you know if you were to use that uh
finer grain
photoshop color wheel with a wide range
of hues
you can play around with the angles and
get different analogous color schemes
okay the last thing i wanted to mention
is
layout and navigation issues and so
you know try to make sure when you're
creating the web pages that
uh you have a clear idea on how people
are going to be navigating your website
provide a clear sense on any single page
on
what else is available on the website
and
you know as i mentioned earlier remember
if you have a successful
website you're gonna have people deep
linking to your web pages
and so any one of your web pages should
make it clear to whoever comes to visit
that particular page that there's a lot
of other stuff available on your website
you should make it very clear how to get
to the home page and have some idea give
them some idea of what the other
sections of your website are
provide a consistent navigation scheme
so
they don't have to every time they go
from one page to the next be like
gosh i don't understand what i'm
supposed to click on to go somewhere
next
and i don't have any dead end pages with
no way out this is something that
you know i've graded a lot of amateur
websites
over my time here at stanford and this
is one of the things that i see a lot i
see
both often people will have web pages
that where it's not
clear how to get to that web page um and
if we weren't actually counting up the
files when we're trying to grade their
project be like
hey i've seen the other web page on the
website look at they've got this extra
html file here i wonder how i was
supposed to get to that
you know if it wasn't for the fact that
we actually look at the html files
we wouldn't you know we just completely
miss it we start at the home page
we visit all the pages that there's
clear links to
and then there's this extra page and you
know nobody knows how to get to that
so uh don't do that a page that is not
clear to
to people how to get to is pretty
useless and similarly
you don't want a page where somebody
clicks on the page and the only way to
get
out of that page is to hit the back
button because
you know uh if somebody ends up deep
linked to that page they're not going to
be able to get
away from that page there's not going to
be able to find a way to the rest of
your website so
you know definitely don't do that
all right so that's it for our little
talk on website design
you